so just like a magician never reveals
his secrets we decided not to post this
video until now that's because we didn't
finish shooting it until now
so we got the idea for brush with death
after looking at shadows on a wall we
were standing at a building that be I
was like so highway and the cars driving
by nice graphic violence yeah hold on
[Music]
okay yeah it's the spiritual violence
the idea for brush with death came from
those forced perspective chalk drawings
that you can only see and make sense of
from the right angle yes what if it
spills across the sidewalk and the
street and then goes up to the wall and
then what if you take that perspective
and you shift it to the point where the
shape stretches out and becomes
unrecognizable like what can you do with
an effect like that so that slows effect
off we use a technique called camera
mapping and basically a camera mapping
takes your picture your drawing and it
projects it from the canvas point of
view on to whatever geometry you have we
would build rough geometry in 3ds max
that mimics the difference in height
between the road sidewalk and the wall
and basically just shoot out an image of
Jake from the cameras perspective now
the thing is the camera is moving like
for example jostling sweeping around it
lines up at one point so he projected
from that one point where he in the wand
to line up then as the camera would move
to its other points it would become
stretched just like those perspective
drawings it's only when you come back to
the right spot
does everything make sense the hard part
was erasing Jake those couple of moments
when he's supposed to be invisible he
runs he jumps into place because it's
easy to paint people out when the camera
is not moving around in space but it's
locked up in one point and just looking
around when the camera is moving you
start getting perspective and parallax
and all this other crazy stuff into the
mix so where this one had to take an
extra step further and actually build
that the 3d representation of the scene
while we use 3ds max for the actual
projection of the characters we're using
After Effects for that 3d kind of
background cleanup there's a Video
Copilot tutorial actually teaching how
to do camera projection with After
Effects that's actually technique we
used in the photo real video as well
those are all the perspective tricks
because we had a couple other things we
wanted to try it for example a door is
painted on the wall and I run through
the door and come out the wall and the
first shot I'm actually in real life I
somehow walk into the wall which has
come into place perspective wise the
next shot I run out of it basically we
filmed me just running up to the wall
like I was going to run into it but then
I actually just leave frame and stop and
then in just cameras States looking at
the wall then over here on our street we
feel me
into an open door cut copy paste that's
it same thing for jumping out fill me
running out of the doorway take that
stick it onto the wall a little bit of a
little work and then it just pans over
to me already standing there ready to go
you could talk about your 3d hammer 3d
hammer time basically all I did is build
a hammer in 3ds max I rented it up from
one perspective then take that and do
the same camera projection technique
that we did for all the other shots yeah
it's the same thing basically instead of
still image it's an animation and the
beginning and end frames are essentially
just stills so actually brush with death
was else in the first video ever where
it got stopped by Street security some
guys on bicycles that rolled over and
they're like you have too many people
here you know you can only have three
crew and one actor and I was like we
only have one actor I mean are you
counting the dog because Jake brothers
dog rocky and and eco myself Evan Jake
and rocky were there and I guess they're
counting the dog as a person because
they said three and then I explained the
concept to them he's like okay so we're
gonna take these people get a camera map
them onto the wall yeah we're gonna
project it out it's like you know it's
like street art but like and then you
come to coming like it's like okay
whatever and really just like the way
with death oddly enough was our most
popular video in Japan I don't know why
anyways guys I hope you enjoyed this a
look into how he made brush with death
its kind of unique it's one close to our
hearts like Samson's highest-rated video
we've ever made because
see on the flipside
[Music]